[Applause]
the far-right and Germany are two things
that sound pretty scary when you put
them together this is why even though
Angela Merkel has won the elections with
a high margin it has been a bittersweet
victory the fact that alternative for
Germany a xenophobic ultra conservative
party has become the third largest
political force is bad enough to make
Merkel rather uneasy we don't need to
beat around the bush
we wanted a better result that is clear
Angela Merkel era visual politic we plan
to do a video this week about Germany
but the current news Forrester snoopers
phone that video so we could have time
to prepare this one explaining what
alternative for journey or AFD as it's
known in Germany is all about and yes I
probably know what you're thinking right
now you're probably thinking come on
Simon how could you not predict that the
far-right would be a big hit in Germany
because well at the end of the day
xenophobic parties they're pretty much
in fashion all across Europe plus aft
you did great in previous local
elections
[Music]
nevertheless most of the polls said that
Germans love moderation above all else
and that's not just the electoral polls
talking but also sociological studies
for instance while in France only 50% of
the population places themselves on the
center of the spectrum this number in
Germany is as high as 76% further
Germans have many reasons to be happy
they almost didn't suffer at all during
the economic crisis and now that our
economy is doing better than ever
salaries are rising there's almost full
employment and companies export abroad
as if there was no tomorrow
so the big question here becomes who
votes for the far right wing in Germany
and most important of all what does
alternative for Germany what are they
really a radical party or is the media
exaggerating well today we're going to
answer all of those questions but as
usual before we get started let's have a
look at the history a party on the
divide yes it is true today alternative
for Germany they are a populist
political party with a big focus on
rejecting immigrants and refugees
specifically they want to reject those
who come from Islamic countries but
despite all of this its origins couldn't
be more different than what it is today
let's go back to the year 2013
now back then all the European media
talked about was the debt crisis that
was happening in countries like Spain
Italy and especially Greece now in case
you don't know the history here let's a
quick summary before 2008 German banks
invested a lot of money in lending to
companies and governments in the south
of Europe and after the financial crisis
of 2008 these countries couldn't give
the money back
in fact they needed even more cash so
that they could afford their current
spending this included things like the
salaries of civil servants highways and
hospitals and as you can imagine paying
day-to-day spending with debt it's a far
from ideal situation
[Applause]
so this is where Angela Merkel comes
along and says all right guys
I'm going to lend you the money I will
even let you give it back whenever you
want but you've got to make some reforms
your economic systems these reforms they
were known as austerity Germany along
side with other northern European
countries wanted to lend money to Italy
Spain and Greece while at the same time
demanding some budget cuts so that these
countries would no longer need to borrow
as much money in the future and so that
they could pay back their debts those
conditions they were seen as pretty
draconian by most of those southern
European countries they were asking the
question what who's Germany to tell us
how we should spend our money meanwhile
some Germans they were also pretty mad
at their governments I mean they were
thinking who are you Merkel to go around
giving money to everyone this is the
European Union not an NGO now among
those angry Germans there were three
famous economists Alexander Gowland Bern
luck and Conrad Adam these were the
founders of the party electoral
alternative 2013 which would later
become alternative for Germany many of
these first supporters were bankers and
university professors from the western
part of Germany cities like Frankfurt
Cologne and Bonn and do you remember
this because it's going to become really
important later on
now in their electoral manifesto they
suggested that Germany should leave the
euro and go back to the German mark and
swell why was that well this is because
they believed that they could avoid
bailouts to poorer economies by doing so
and even more importantly they could
protect their economy from a likely
devaluation of the euro as we've said in
previous videos Germany's success was
partly due to their strong currency
but Spain and Greece they were pushing
the European Central Bank to print more
money so that they could pay their debts
back and as you probably know economists
they thought that was a pretty bad idea
the first stereotypical AFD voters
weren't like the stereotype of an
extreme right-wing hooligan they were
considered to be businessmen economists
and university teachers this is why the
media started calling this party that
quote teachers party and why they
couldn't win a single MP during the
federal elections of 2013 I mean think
about it monetary policy is not exactly
a sexy topic for an electoral campaign I
mean pretty much only you guys who are
watching this video care about that kind
of topic
nonetheless the fate of alternative for
Germany was to change in July of 2015 at
that moment the Economist Bern La Crosse
the Chairman bar to the brand new leader
Frau Petri she had other plans unlike
the previous leaders Petri came from the
eastern part of the country and this
means she brought a totally different
political culture for her monetary
policy deficit and fiscal responsibility
wasn't really that important instead she
knew there was the big nish of voters
who wanted an iron fist on things like
immigration and national identity
besides these kind of suggestions would
give her the support of other leaders
like Nigel Faraj from Britain see you
Kipp party marine lepen from the
National Front in France and of course
our favourite politician than the visual
politic mascot yes might have you of
course we are talking about the one and
only leader of Germany's far right-wing
party meets Putin allies in Moscow
I know I know dad Amir footin is an ever
popular topic here at visual politic but
I mean how could we resist talking about
him now during this time thousands of
refugees from Syria Iraq and Libya they
came to Germany and Angela Merkel she
welcomes them with arms wide open and
well some Germans they didn't really
like this so in the regional elections
of 2016 alternative for Germany launched
an electoral platform which had nothing
to do with what the founders had in mind
at the beginning this is why many of
those economists they jumped ship among
them burn luck who was the first
president
[Music]
[Applause]
this party has fallen irretrievably into
the wrong hands
ban Luka since then alternative for
Germany has had two factions fighting
each other on the one hand we have the
people left over from the first group
but they are less and less important
everyday and on the other hand we have
those who came under the leadership of
Frau Petri this new political structure
it does mean more voters but it also
means more problems
the f t's current crisis was triggered
in mid-january through a taboo breaking
speech by right-winger bjorn hookah who
in a beer hall in dresden called for a
hundred eighty degree turn in germany's
culture of remembering and atoning for
the nazi era regardless of how far
right-wing you want to be these kind of
things they're not really cool in
Germany and this created many problems
for mrs. Petri there are some
investigations open because apparently
some of the proposals on her program
might be illegal remember that German
law is made to avoid any resurgence of
Nazism the issues in this party are big
enough that even Frau Pech RIA herself
had to resign one day after this last
election due to infighting with some of
the more extreme factions of the party
nevertheless with or without the
unfortunate weights and the internal
division alternative for Germany has
become the big surprise from this
election so the question now becomes who
voted for them well let's take a look at
this
[Music]
history of two Germany's for the past
few years the German economy has been on
fire salaries are growing companies are
exporting and inequality is almost
non-existent
well actually just hold on familiar
because that last that it's not exactly
sure now of course there is almost no
poverty on the streets and there are
factories all over the country but when
we look at the income distribution by
regions do you see a clear division if
you pay attention to this map you'll see
a blue part and a red part
[Music]
the blue part is the wealthiest the red
part is the poorest the blue part is
what used to be Western Germany and the
red part is what used to be eastern
Germany communist Germany that eastern
part of the country is the Germany that
went capitalist in 1989 but still
doesn't have the same standard of living
as the West if you visit a city like
Dresden in eastern Germany you will see
lots of construction going on most of
the buildings they were completed just a
couple of years ago this is indicative
that the reunification of Germany is
still very much an ongoing process now
of course if we compare the standard of
living of an Eastern German with a creek
or a Spaniard it doesn't look that bad
but Germans they like to be compared
with other Germans and when you do that
things look way worse Schmidt doesn't
have enough industrial opportunity and
it lacks proper educational facilities a
large sport and cultural center aren't
enough to keep people from leaving the
city it's dead quiet in the town centre
young people have left in droves for
bigger cities in the West a sculpture on
the riverbank mirrors the city's
troubled hopes for the future in this
city the city of chouette alternative
for Germany got over 20% of the votes
and a little further south in the state
of Saxony most people are voting for the
far-right but hold on a minute because
we're not just talking about the economy
here we're talking about the totally
different culture think about it
East Germans lived for entire
generations under a totally different
political system this means a different
education a different lifestyle and
different values here moderation it's
not really a good thing
in fact the left-wing party Die Linke er
gets most of its votes in eastern Berlin
but there's more than that well Western
Germans spent decades remembering their
Nazi past the government of the
Democratic Republic of Germany tried to
create a new sense of national pride so
when an aft candidate says that we must
appreciate the courage of the German
soldiers during World War two Germans
from Cologne are frightened but Germans
from Leipzig say well okay whatever all
right but now there is a really
important question why is eastern
Germany is so much against refugees and
immigrants well many of you might think
this is because they are tired of
Muslims who don't want to integrate into
their culture right well here comes a
number that is going to absolutely blow
your mind
there aren't 9 million immigrants living
in Germany at less than 500,000 live in
East Germany
[Music]
and when you really think about it this
makes total sense I mean those who moved
to Germany they want to be in the
wealthiest regions so if you walk down
the streets of Dresden you're hardly
ever going to see a woman covering her
head with a hijab and then guess who is
the biggest immigrant community in
eastern Germany while surprise surprise
that would be the Russians more than
half of the immigrants living on this
side of the country come from the lands
of Putin and of course they are the
biggest audience for German Russia today
and well this explains things like this
AFD deploys double-headed eagle to snare
russian german voters so now the
question becomes do you think
alternative for Germany can keep growing
in the next election or will its
internal divisions end up destroying the
party and what do you think this party
can achieve over the next four years
please do let us know in the comments
section below
meanwhile if you want to know why
Germany is the world's Factory do click
on this video and also rather to visit
Theory consider media podcast they
provided the vocals in this video that
are not mine and as always we publish
new videos every Monday and Thursday so
hit that subscribe button and you will
not miss any of those videos and don't
forget to give us a thumbs up if you
enjoyed this video and as always I'll
see you in the next one and if you want
to learn more about politics and hear
even more of my lovely voice you can
join us at reconsider media we have a
podcast at reconsidered Mediacom slash
podcast see you there
[Music]